three two one
one
yeah drug scenes are a part of a lot of
movies and tv shows
in breaking bad the meth that they
smoked was actually blue rock candy
right now i'm crushing up this meth so
we can get it
into a consistency that is more smokable
[Music]
wow while all these drugs look real
accuracy is only one part of the job
any fake drug whether it's snorted
puffed or injected
has to be safe for the actor something
that hasn't always been the case
on film sets striking that perfect
balance is where a prop master like joel
barkel comes in
joel has made fake drugs for shows like
the sopranos and blue bloods
and he says making these drugs act real
is always the first hurdle
let's take a simple example to start
it's not enough for a prop joint to look
realistic
it also has to produce the right kind of
smoke substituting tobacco for cannabis
seems like an easy solution but tobacco
smoke isn't as heavy as cannabis smoke
and that means it won't look quite right
so prop masters use a cannabis strain
that lacks thc
for scenes that involve smoking weed i
cannot say that this looks any different
than
the cannabis smoke that i have seen in
my life it
looks like a real joint hits like one
too
it's pretty harsh for other drugs like
heroin prop masters need to have
different mixtures of the fake drug
ready
depending on if the scene calls for
melting it or not for static shots
joel has found that the best looking
fake heroine comes from a combination of
pancake waffle mix and cocoa powder
it's just all about getting the color
all these things are about color
consistency etc it just reads really
well on camera
but for scenes that require the drug to
actually be heated up on camera
a completely different fake heroin
mixture is swapped in because the
pancake mix doesn't melt very well
i use brown sugar little bit of water to
get the the bubbly effect
while brown sugar doesn't look very much
like powdered heroin it mimics melted
heroin quite well
matching the sticky look of the bubbles
creating realistic fake drugs that look
good in close-up shots is one thing but
it gets even more complicated when an
actor has to take these fake drugs on
screen
for scenes that require an actor to
shoot up with a needle the needle can't
actually penetrate the actor's skin
but they need to show the syringe
injecting the fake drugs so for these
situations
a specially engineered needle is used
this is a retractable syringe
this is the greatest syringe to use for
on camera because what it does
is the plunger is ready to just force
forward and it'll
retract into itself along with the
needle as you push
the pump into the syringe the liquid
disappears
inside a tube and vice versa too let's
say
a scene where he needed to draw blood
from an actor you could do the same
thing you have
red fluid red liquid already inside
there
and pull this out joel also provides
real needles to use for shots that don't
require faking injections or drawing
blood when i send them out
you'll have a kit in this case this
one's dulled so i don't send like a
really sharp tip out and so that way
they can do
this on camera as they're about to
inject and then if they're going to
actually do the injection
they'd have a retractable one as it's
standing nailing the look of a
substitute is just one part of the job
joel has the added challenge of making
sure any fake drug is also safe for the
actor
and hollywood hasn't always gotten that
right for example the fake cocaine that
was used on the set of scarface
caused minor but permanent damage to al
pacino's nasal passage
this injury was likely the result of the
quantity and quality of the film's fake
cocaine which in this case was powdered
baby laxatives
in order to avoid any sort of accidents
or injuries like this
joel works directly with actors to
prepare them for using fake drugs
you have to think of them at all times
if you talk to them about any allergies
it's almost like being a prop doctor
joel said that one of the most common
allergies that he has to look out for is
lactose intolerance because powdered
lactose is often used as fake cocaine
and so if they are lactose intolerant
obviously you're not going to use the
lactose
that gives you the next option which is
inositol
inositol is a vitamin b complex that is
safe to ingest
it looks so much like cocaine the drug
dealers have been known to use it to cut
the actual stuff
joel said that this prop cocaine is so
harmless that it shouldn't even irritate
an actor's nostrils when they snort it
joel lent me some inositol so that i
could check it out for myself
sweet this is wild
oh yeah it doesn't really feel like
anything
no no stinging or anything like that wow
yeah that was easy
good i'm actually i'm just shocked at
how it's not that it was pleasant it was
an extremely neutral experience
right which is i guess what you would
want and that's what you want you want
them to be able to
act and not you know tearing up and
grinding
yeah totally when any actor is snorting
ingesting fake cocaine it's good to have
a nasal spray and you're
going to offer them up you know just
after afterwards or in between takes if
you need to
just clear it all out while prop drugs
have gotten safer since the days of
scarface
things can still go wrong while filming
2013's the wolf of wall street
actor jonah hill became ill after
sorting too much vitamin d
powder during production i did so much
fake cocaine in wolf of wall street i
got bronchitis for three weeks it had to
be specialized yeah
while vitamin d powder is theoretically
completely safe to ingest
inhaling the powder almost every day for
several weeks straight
caused an infection in his lungs just as
actors stopped using real cigarettes on
screen after the health risks of smoking
became widely publicized
actors have recently become more
conscious of the fake drugs that they
might have to ingest
some prop masters have created rigs with
a suction device that will suck up the
fake drugs for the actor
to hide this rig the tip of the hose is
wrapped in a dollar bill
the hose can then be pushed up an
actor's shirt and out their sleeve
and then the right camera angle and
lighting are used so that only the
dollar bill
tip is exposed you can see this
ingestion free technique in the scene
with army hammer in 2018's sorry to
bother you
they chose to use the rig because there
was so much fake cocaine that needed to
be snorted
for joel's suction rig he uses a manual
pump so it functions more like a human
lawn
you could use a compressor as well with
this but i thought i thought it was
gonna be
a compressor would be way too much power
all right that looks good okay so on
three two
one go okay
three two one
yeah as you can see
the final shot looks pretty good
especially for having such minimal setup
time
joel said that these rigs aren't used
very often but i'd expect to see them
become more common in the future
it was pretty easy to use and i didn't
have to snort anything myself
it would definitely be a nice option to
have if there was a scene
where i knew i'd be doing a lot of takes
figuring out fake drugs from movies
isn't as simple as finding one solution
like in the case of cocaine it's about
figuring out better and better
alternatives that look great on screen
and keep actors as safe as possible each
iteration becoming a small part of
hollywood history
and constantly reaching for a new high
we didn't do the whole thing okay hold
on
i mentioned this before but this whole
table looks like a dare ad
that i would like see whenever i was in
like elementary school with like the
dirty spoon and everything